louis xiv was perhaps the last great
monarch
the man reigned over france for a whole
72 years
he was the definition of royalty and
viewed himself as a representative of
god
his subjects referred to him as not just
the king but the sun king
and since everything revolves around the
sun naturally france revolved around him
fast forward two generations later and
you had louis xvi
the last monarch of france that was
executed with a guillotine
humanity decided that they finally had
enough of the idea that their rights
belonged to the gods and kings that
ruled over them
and instead they now believe that their
sovereign rights belong to them
the people selfish right now this is
definitely an
inconvenience to the aspiring
power-hungry individual like ourselves
but not to worry because even though you
can't be a king anymore
there is an alternative as democracy
started popping up all over the world
would be kings realized that they
couldn't just seize power by force or
violence alone anymore
sure you can definitely still seize
power today with a coup invasions
assassinations
but what these early democratic
dictators of the 21st century learned
is that naked power has an expiration
date
if you seize power through force alone
was to stop your competitors from doing
the same to you
now that plugs think that they have
rights or whatever it would only make
sense that they toppled the man that
took the rights away wouldn't it
so how long do you honestly expect to
last we need a better method
not just a better way of seizing power
but a better way of maintaining
said power after you get it a modern day
take on the kings of the past but that
can coexist in our more democratic world
we need to learn how to be a dictator
within every single crisis there's an
opportunity
which brings us to the first step in our
quest to becoming a dictator
getting into power now under normal
circumstances why would the average
population want a dictator to take over
that's why when you look throughout
history every single dictator rose to
power during a crisis
kim il-sung took over war-torn north
korea after world war ii
for mussolini he yelled from the
rooftops that italy needed a dictator to
save them from a communist uprising
for stalin it was after lenin died and
the list goes on
why is this the case because in times of
crisis when everyone is suffering people
fall back onto those old tribal
instincts from our hunter-gatherer days
they instinctively follow whoever
promises change answers to guide their
nation to a better future
they'll follow whoever offers them
refuge to their meager existence
someone that promises to take their
country to a better fairer place
so what's going to be the modern day
crisis you use
the more larger than life the more
god-like you appear to the masses
the easier everything will be to do this
view yourself as kind of like a
religious leader
but instead of traditional religion you
preach your political religion
you want people to worship you exactly
like how they will worship a cult leader
or a prophet
why well since democracies are based on
the support of the people on the vote of
the people
if people worship you like they would a
cult leader you will have the people's
democracy
in the palm of your hands and if any of
your rivals try to take you down
they would have to go up against all
your devoted cult followers as well
why do you think nearly every
authoritarian regime in the past and
present from soviet russia to modern day
china persecuting falun gong to north
korea are pretty
atheists it's so like you the leader can
fill that sacred religious void in the
hearts and minds of the public
instead of some god it's a weapon
a weapon named right at the hearts and
minds of the weak and the desperate it
will give us control of it
our school curriculum is dedicated to
learn about
like the greatness of the dear leaders
they literally
copy the bible if you think about it so
they put
kimier song as the god who loved us who
was chosen by this
universe and loves us so much he gave us
his son kim jong-il which is jesus
and when we die we become with them and
we go like eternal paradise with them
pick an edgy sounding ideology off the
internet and put your own twist on it to
use as your gospel
for kim it was socialism and communism
but with self-reliance which he branded
as jouche
for mussolini it was fascism but it was
really just centered around how he was
the best for the job
basically if it feels new to the people
if it makes them feel good and if it
sounds fair and just
you're golden don't get hung up on this
too much your political ideology is just
for appearances it's just the vehicle
you're gonna use to seize power
once you're in power all that stuff can
go out the window
as shakespeare said all the world's a
stage and as a political cult leader you
have to treat yourself as an actor on
that stage
hitler saw himself as europe's greatest
actor mussolini saw himself as italy's
finest actor
he carefully studied certain gestures
and poses to see which commanded the
most authority
he tensed up his facial muscles jaw and
voice in public while letting them relax
in privates every word every gesture
every tonal change in your voice every
aspect of your body language contributes
to putting the populace under your spell
so make sure you make the most of it get
in front of the public eye through
speeches
rallies tours tv appearances interviews
social media the more public
support you have the easier it will be
to rise up in power and when the time is
right it's time to take the throne
now there's no real set way to go about
this in the case of north korea
kim il-sung was luckily put in power by
the soviets without actually having much
public support
for mussolini he convinced everyone that
only he could save italy and was granted
the prime minister position
in your case if you have enough public
support maybe a violent coup will work
but however you seize the throne it's
time to get that propaganda machine
running
[Music]
as you get more power you want to use
mass media to make yourself omnipresent
plaster your face literally everywhere
have your writings and speeches on
repeat on news stations social media
radio
set up loudspeakers and public squares
like mussolini did have mainstream media
promote and spread positive stories
about yourself while silencing the
centers
rename streets cities factories after
your holiness like stalin did
it was not a rare incident for workers
to compose a letter to stalin
during a meeting in the stalin house of
culture of the stalin factory on styling
square
in the city of starlinsk depending on
how desperate your subjects are
exaggerate your story like kim il-sung
did
like how he had super powers could fly
to the air tunnel through mountains that
kind of stuff
i heard he doesn't pee or poop he works
so hard
he burns the energy from inside you tell
me my man doesn't have think of poo
basically you want your subjects to feel
as if wherever they go
their great leader is watching over
their shoulders 24 7.
i hope this office isn't blocked of
course
comrade stalin would be able to tell the
difference he's the great man with the
great eon
two great ears sharp you know when i was
a child first the very first thing that
my parents my mom told
me was not to even whisper
because the ma the birds and mice could
hear me
what if i sleep some wrong words
it's not gonna just kill that person it
kills
entire three generations of that family
you also want to make it a requirement
to publicly praise you and worship you
or else they'll face some severe
punishments
why do you think north korea forces
everyone to bow to their giant statues
every time they pass by
why do you think xi jinping of china
forces subjects to repeat phrases like i
love the chinese communist party they're
not stupid they know people aren't just
gonna magically love them just because
they bow to a statue
no the goal is to create that illusion
of public support as you get more and
more tyrannical
if you're in north korea and everyone
around you is worshiping and praising
kim jong-un
and you know that people who question
him get snitched on and are thrown into
labor camps or killed
who can you trust who can you confide to
forcing people to praise the leader in
public makes it harder for people to
band together to try to take you down
or in other words if everyone is lying
how do you know who's really lying
i'm gonna have to report this
conversation threatening to do harm
or obstruct any member of the presidium
in the process of looking at your
face
speaking of punishments as you start to
act like more of a dictator
you're gonna have people who don't
support you so you're gonna need
punishments to keep them in line
the go-to punishment every dictatorship
has used in the past are for some reason
labor camps
but the more severe punishments being
death of course and as your populist
becomes more and more submissive
you can have more and more severe
punishments a man wrapped the book with
a newspaper containing kim il-sung
five years in the labor camp a man
touched up a badly executed poster of
his great leader
five years for youtube this combination
of pure
fear and heavenly worship makes for a
powerful mix
when kim il-sung died and you see
everyone crying hysterically
it wasn't just because those people
genuinely love their benevolent leader
no i'm sure there were some people like
that but it was also because if you
didn't join in on that mass hysteria you
would stick out like a sword thumb and
the secret police would haul you off to
a labor camp
this made the mob try to outdo one
another in morning so they wouldn't get
punished
[Applause]
so this terror makes people display more
public admiration for their great leader
which increases that cult effect which
increases the terror which increases the
cult
and so solidifying your rule a vicious
yet genius cycle
[Music]
from there all you have to do to
increase your power is scale up the
insanity
open more labor camps and gulags ban all
foreign bucks like north korea did back
in 1968
because a more uneducated populace is
always easier to control
be like stalin and force all
broadcasters to end every sentence they
say with
thank you stalin or for i am joyous
stalin
organize your subjects in the classes
based on their loyalty to you and use
that to determine how much food rations
they get their education
employment everything just like north
korea even where i live
who i can marry what can i do in life is
determined
by my political class in the in the
country
if you think this sounds eerily similar
to china's social credit score system
that's because it pretty much is being
discredited makes it hard to get a job
a loan a hotel room or put kids in
certain schools
as you give speeches around the country
send pink slips ordering locals to
attend or they'll get fined or prison
time
in the case of mussolini ban things that
make people feel like individuals like
love songs love stories folk tales
theaters classical music just like north
korea
the regime the government telling us
what to wear
what kind of haircut you can have what
kind of makeup you can have what kind of
pants you can wear what kind of song you
can sing
what kind of movie you can watch what
kind of dance you can dance
purge out the government of people who
disagree with you and replace them with
a bunch of yes men
rewrite history to glorify you you
secret police spies informants
interrogators torturers the sky is the
limit
and if you do your job right the next
generation that grows up under your
world will have no idea how things were
in the before world when the first
generation dies off
you'll be left with a populist that
thinks that this is just how things are
and they won't even know what the word
freedom is much or less what it means
but the real test of your world the real
test of your dictatorship is whether or
not you're number
one die of natural causes like how mao
zeidang of china and joseph stalin did
and number two if your reign will live
on after you're gone
making north korea history's ultimate
dictatorship that's three generations
deep
if you don't have what it takes to be a
dictator or you don't want to get
violently overthrown
well this is where today's sponsor comes
in there is none
because apparently this video was too
controversial
so i tell you what if you enjoyed this
video and want to support us financially
so we can make more and better videos
check out a course i made on how to go
remotes this is how i got my start in
this whole make money online thing with
a 40
per hour work from home web dev job when
i was 19 years old and i believe that
this is the most practical way for you
to get started as well
you don't have to start a business from
scratch you learn valuable skills on
your own time while making consistent
money so you're not starving to death
like those poor people in north korea
and as we've seen in recent times remote
jobs are a lot less fragile than
traditional ones
and my favorite part is that you can use
remote jobs as a jumping off point for
whatever you want
want to eventually get into business
like i did you learn a lot of valuable
skills that transfer over and you can
use your more flexible schedule to work
on a side hustle at the same time
want to be a digital nomad traveling the
world there's an entire community of
remote workers doing that
and just like how companies are
realizing they shouldn't have their
entire supply chain completely dependent
on one place like china
companies are also realizing that they
shouldn't just rely on in-person
employees alone
and if i had to guess that trend will
continue and with this course it walks
you through what jobs to go after based
on your personality what the best rest
of the learner are standing out when
applying for jobs interviews
basically everything you need from start
to finish that i wish i would have known
and you can start your remote journey
right now and support this ridiculous
channel at the same time by going to
jaketran dot io slash capital lla with
the link below
again that's jaketrend.ioslash capital
lla with the link below
the sweet smell of california fires at
night so what kind of dictatorship are
you guys gonna start let me know in the
comments below
theoretically of course if you enjoyed
this video there are plenty of other
video essays coming out for free every
single week on business
war crime power so subscribe and turn on
that notification bell
if you want behind the scenes stuff then
the life kind of stuff
memes me complaining about stuff online
you can follow me on instagram
jaketrand.io but that's gonna wrap it up
for this video thank you guys so much
for watching you've been awesome i've
been jake as always stay dangerous and
i'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you